[Music]
and selfies it's catch suspect news who
submitted by Walker the Texas Ranger
yeah that show is dog Chuck Norris
watches this it was the best when I time
doing a flying side kick through the
shield are the car windshield I was like
oh I want to try that with your cowboy
boots on now Boyan and then the Bowflex
a lot of us like because of Chuck really
police posted several funny selfies of a
robbery suspect on Facebook hoping it
will lead to her capture yeah they do
all the time though now yeah like if
someone's run around they'll try to hack
in their Instagram and if a school
trustee things and yeah I think this one
stood out for a lot of people because of
the selfies that they chose oh it's like
just like titty one can we see them now
God one I say in a [ __ ] one but it cost
Dixit I'm addicted are you
you ever been getting my texts on
Instagram how do you put dictaphone it's
not Instagram just [ __ ] I don't know
like bulge pics sure Oh
like someone take a dick pic and in send
it to the Senate you and diem oh I
thought it's all about public posts
kindly for your selfies right I figured
they just stole it from Facebook
that's what popped up like they hacked
into their yeah stole it and then said
hey have you seen this mmm give Oakland
dick pic to those self appreciating dick
take dick pics huh it's a pro-social
weird voice yeah so this one my name is
Megan she's 25 years old from Texas so
she was caught shoplifting at a Walmart
what the [ __ ] would she tell with the
[ __ ] you shoplift at Walmart by like
midnight I really need this off-brand
soda yes like what honest Custer oh
parts over you're defending Walmart wall
paper you can do finger knit ring
there's a lot of dope stuff you know
what that is true because I don't know
what you're inspired to do at 2:00 a.m.
yeah like sometimes you just go I need a
[ __ ] pink where can you get an easel
a [ __ ] canvas and paint [ __ ] at to a
hole Michael's ain't open and a car
battery
[ __ ] crackhead Walmart's weird cuz
that is like food now so you get all
that and a head of lettuce that's weird
I don't want that I don't want to buy
tires and lettuce from when you comply
[ __ ] paparazzi newspaper on the same
time you need underwear you need to
[ __ ] build a sandwich while you're
painting yeah with an axe and a and a
box of chocolates and a dog leash what
yeah where you gonna go at 2:00 a.m.
roll balls Bentley huh
yeah so this woman she had her
five-year-old daughter with her as she
was shoplifting at Walmart oh that's
genius not just by show it in her diaper
yeah and so when the loss prevention
officer went over to her that
subtraction of when people need such an
official name even though that's a
greeter at the [ __ ] place like any
welcome to Walmart it's a pleasure as a
blowback yeah a little bad person when
this austere was heading over to her
that's when she got into her 2013 Dodge
Challenger and tried to run over oh [ __ ]
that person twice and so luckily no one
was injured but then that's what when it
led into a 90 miles an hour features
with a baby in the car with it with her
daughter in the car mmm so as police
were chasing her but she got away
what kind of Challenger she got she got
the SRT she got this okay how she cheers
to that David demon yeah how he had only
a challenge to helicam the Hellcat
either way what the hell what a kingster
she got away - what is she feeling from
Walmart that that's valuable you know I
don't know either how come the caller
didn't catch her
I don't I'm not sure about those pirates
trips that they throw out I didn't do
that I ran out she quit watching fast
and furious she probably a sub maneuvers
but even at hand in it like you could
still catch my line D maybe that's crazy
I think there are some states maybe I'm
wrong go quote me back off yeah you're
not allowed to chase that yeah counting
on it where can I get a list of these
states
I thought LA was one of where they need
to back off because of the Stasi I don't
think so I imagine Texas to be more way
more hardcore you purchase shotgun on
this right now so now the police are
searching for her and these are the
photos I posted
so here was that once the phony no it's
Harley Quinn the one that did a little
bit too much crack oh [ __ ] Wow
yeah so they're posting different images
of her in case they I don't think these
were meant to be funny I think this is
her she's sexy yeah oh that's what about
that what do we does look like she's
trying to be funny she just looks like
her wonderful cat this is all the thing
for Daisy how is this possible she looks
like a different girl it's not facing
their myspace Twitter what the [ __ ] is
that she looks like a ghoul egg
jennamarbles jennamarblesvlog what
perfect noise or soliton yeah point
George what the hell is going on yeah so
these are all the selfies that the
police posted over and she knows how to
drive
why does this she look like a 55 year
old trailer trash mom in this picture 26
that will oh dude she's an age chameleon
225 women when you're young she's great
did she she goes from 15 to 83 and she
goes from crackhead to obese [ __ ]
Walmart that's what I haven't caught her
still like what does she's like eight
different people tough spot
she's like the ultimate superhero where
do you police when they say post that
were they post on on their Facebook page
oh and you just follow your local
Facebook you know one consistent thing
about her disguise though is she's all
the women of the trailer park like
that's fast yeah she can't execute the
elegant look whatsoever like she's
either a [ __ ] Juggalo or should you
think of [ __ ] Tweaker or she's
someone's obese mom in the trailer park
kind of like Tyler Perry's trailer trash
but Toy Fair places where she's like all
the different spectrum of the trailer
park that baby blue eye shadow
yeah she's like Mimi from Drew Carey
what year what year do we have oh yeah
this just goes makeup like that yeah
yeah I felt like 1996 like yeah I do
your thing she's not another 2000 MD nah
man
what year was it it looks like they took
that Jonah just popped it on her face
hahaha
girl yes and Ashley is facing charges of
aggravated robbery and child
endangerment but they still haven't
found it on this okay oh really I was
just kidding
as of now they could have they could
torture was way more she's a chameleon
she got that Challenger SRT I wouldn't
be able to find her she could come to
Walmart the next day if she looks like
one of those uh people I did she
probably did she's probably got 20 more
looks I haven't seen sure there's a
[ __ ] retired stripper look low budget
casino cocktail waitress look dude
that's so bad yeah man she's done
something I didn't think people were
like that no more 2007 feel bad for a
kid we're gonna crush I'm gonna spy us
be like a [ __ ] method like her dude
what the hell probably drugs yeah
drugs are stupidity that's kind of what
I land everything up I kind of give it
to her that at least she could drive
dude yeah I couldn't join the fast fast
seven fast a team comes out of the new
criminal the wall of our bus she's like
the opening chase team yeah all of a
sudden they have dope rims and they're
still not popping on the [ __ ] demon
yeah a lot of people on this post though
they're just like how is this the same
person one two it's like really guys you
have to pick like the most ridiculous
selfies of you I can see why the cops
did it though cuz it's like it could be
this suspicious get the woman that looks
like I won't get crazy yeah that's crazy
so she's like the goth girl now she's
like the bootleg biggest girl they're
all weird girl now it's the [ __ ]
sports girl exes yeah it's the Dallas
Cowboy fan girl backyard barbecue girl
substances executors workers yeah I feel
like it's not a Texas thing I don't
think so I haven't seen I feel like that
the Vegas thing yeah I feel like it's
the Vegas hmm
now this one is I'm not too sure if I
said boy George oh boy George George I
just thought it was a fluid genders look
yeah 2017 fluid gender look esta MySpace
yeah this is the myspace photo yeah that
one's the straight up trailer mom
50-year old trailer mom yeah she got
that lipstick that matches her skin tone
look flirting with her
17-year old boyfriend what's between
Billa she's that 43 year old mom that
wants to [ __ ] her daughter's boyfriend
what's your son doing to this [ __ ]
got stung by a bee this one I gotta I
gotta stop [ __ ] clowning on people
that I see it's so difficult like the
first thing I think of is like wow I've
seen you somewhere
maybe Wawa I was like the whole length
of it she got yeah she's like all the
people of Walmart
why is it difficult to the clowns are
like why do you know you morally feel
bad I just feel like maybe that's not
nice but she's a bad person everybody in
the world is [ __ ] oh I don't know
maybe maybe uh maybe I should change my
ways I just can't stop it like
everywhere I walk down the street I see
a lady pushing a cart and I'm just like
you probably [ __ ] [ __ ] up in life
tax evasion you should stop that yeah
I'm not I just look at the business guy
walking down I'm looking at him like and
you look like you [ __ ] beat up kids
for fun yeah what's up guys thanks for
watching we are going to regularly start
posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there a lot videos click over here
[Music]